marylise lebranchu la ministre de la
décentralisation et de la fonction
publique est l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir madame et merci d'être avec nous
donc pour ce rendez-vous de public sénat
avec l' agence france-presse
c'est à dire ce soir avec perrine
tarneaud et deborah cloud avec donc
trois grandes parties comme chaque
semaine et trois grandes questions pour
vous madame la ministre d'abord est ce
la chienlit en france c'est la vision en
tous les cas que donnent les violences
et air france la dernière fusillade dont
a été victime un policier puis la grève
des médecins selon nicolas sarkozy vous
pourrez lui répondre dans un instant
deuxième question à propos des
fonctionnaires est ce que dans notre
pays toute réforme est impossible la cgt
appelle à une journée d'actions jeudi
notamment contre vos projets pour
réformer la carrière des fonctionnaires
enfin troisième question en lien avec
les régionales est ce que vous dites
allez martine vas-y 1 puisque on envie
de savoir si vous allez peut-être vous
résoudre tout à l'heure à demander à
votre grande amie martine aubry de se
lancer dans le combat face à la menace
du front national dans le nord
et puis vous même vous nous direz si
vous pourrez peut-être aller au combat
en bretagne puisque la question se pose
on vous la posera tout à l'heure air
france donc d'abord air france c'est le
résumé de la france si on lit un peu la
presse internationale trop de personnel
pas assez d'heures de travail et puis
une incapacité à se réformer voilà en
tous les cas ce qu'on entend dans qu'est
ce qu'on lit dans toute la presse
internationale depuis hier depuis cette
agression violente de deux dirigeants de
la compagnie les images encore bien sûr
sont dans toutes les mémoires tentent
elles sont marquantes
nicolas sarkozy va donc plus loin
aujourd'hui que la condamnation générale
en dénonçant la chienlit le délitement
de l'état c'est un mot qui est repris
chez les républicains écouté par exemple
le député alain chrétien
où étiez vous où êtes vous monsieur le
premier ministre
où est l'état actionnaire qui doit taper
du poing sur la table pour faire cesser
cette chienlit qui portent atteinte à
l'un des fleurons d'autres pays
alors madame la ministre est ce que
c'est la chienlit en france en raison du
pouvoir socialiste
d'abord je pense que les responsables
politiques doivent toujours faire
attention aux mots qu'ils emploient sur
l'île
dont on se souvient quand on lit son
histoire quand on l'a vécu c'est tout le
monde dans la rue plus d'autorité une
situation pré révolutionnaire le monde
sortir mais souvent plus dans la poche
du général de gaulle 1 je pense que
toute personne raisonnable se rend
compte qui n'est pas du tout c'est pas
du tout de même nature on a un grand
conflit non à l'intérieur d'une grande
entreprise dont on est fier et qui vend
air france dans lequel l'état 17% du
capital à une négociation qui échoue
avec un nez syndicat le snpl le syndicat
des pilotes et du coup la direction qui
propose parce qu'il y à un échec avec
les pilotes
j'ai pris mes 2900 emplois dans d'autres
catégories donc effectivement il ya
quelque chose de très dur à vivre pour
les autres qui disent oui mais si elle a
eu une négociation avec les pilotes moi
je ne serai pas licencier
est ce que vous dites est ce que vous
êtes en train de dire que la violence
physique répond à une certaine violence
sociale je pense que c'est une situation
extraordinaire et moi je prends les
paroles du drh lui même air france qui
dit attention
ne jetez pas l'opprobre sur tous les
syndicalistes il s'agit de quelques-uns
qui ont voulu manifester qui ont été
débordés par leur propre colère on voit
bien sur les images il faut reprendre le
dialogue social je pense que rien ne se
règle dans une grande entreprise
c'est grave mais voilà le mot chienlit
serait dangereux selon vous c'est parce
que vous dites aux français ça y est
depuis air france tout le monde est dans
la rue c'est fini a plus d'autorité et
plus de corps intermédiaires
allez-y sous les revendiquer cours est
dehors et revendique est c'est quasi un
appel alors il faut faire attention
c'est un appel à la russie on n'aime pas
dans la rue aujourd'hui
air france s'était pas dans la rue c'est
une vraie un vrai heures en train drh
qui d'ailleurs lui est raisonnable dans
son vocabulaire et des syndicats dans la
bouche de nicolas sarkozy c'est un appel
à descendre dans la rue alors que
historiquement vous l'avez dit
général de gaulle avait utilisé ce mot
là pour vider la rue l odéon si nicolas
sarkozy ne se souvient plus de l'état du
pays
quand le général de gaulle a osé
utiliser ce mot ou bien on vit pas dans
la même france et je pense qu faire
attention
notre pays est fragilisé par la crise
nicolas sarkozy sait qu'elle a commencé
en 2008 que même si qui que ce soit
on était tous au gouvernement c'est
difficile pour tout le monde c'est
difficile pour nous c'est difficile pour
air france dans un autre contexte on est
dans une situation de tension politique
de tension démographique et de tensions
sociales pour en rajouter et je pense
que quand on est dans une situation de
tension il faut appeler à la
responsabilité ce que le premier
ministre a fait tout à leur répondant au
député que vous avez cités en disant il
faut que les pilotes aussi reviennent
autour de la table appel à la raison
appel à la responsabilité appel au calme
à la sérénité et à l'as alors est-ce
qu'il faut quand même plus d'autorité
marylise lebranchu puisque christiane
taubira est également prise pour cible
après cette fusillade donc la suite à un
braquage en seine saint denis un
policier a été blessé par un détenu en
cavale acquis une permission de sortie
avait été accordé vous êtes quand même
s'ils ont bien sûr vrai veut vraiment
jouer à la polémique et au fait qu'on
est en train de
il ya des faits le dating le détenu en
cavale a donc bénéficié d'une permission
il avait un lourd antécédents
judiciaires une traîne quand la valeur
parce que il a eu une permission
pourquoi elle a une permission parce
qu'elle est une loi votée en 2004 ne se
sarkozy était présente dans le public
qui écrit un certain nombre de motifs
pour lesquels avant qu'il ne soit
considérée comme radicaliser certains
nombre de motifs pour lesquels on peut
accorder une sortie
alors quand on fertile loin on regarde
qu'effectivement sur certaines
applications de cette loi la sortie de
cet homme le fait qu'ils soient partis
n'est pas rentré l'aéro sauver mais il
s'est sauvé la loi et de 2004
donc moi j'ai envie de dire à monsieur
sarkozy a su bien vos responsabilités ce
que dit christiane taubira est simple et
il faut revoir la loi de 2004
y compris sur les conditions de sortie
quand les gens se radicalise parce que
ce n'est pas n'importe quel individu
donc moi je pense que quand on est m non
c'est un président de la république et
qu'on aspire peut-être je ne sais enfin
il sort à leur devenir
il faut être extrêmement attentif aux
mots qu'on emploie aux expressions qu'on
emploie ne pas faire comme si rien
n'existait quand on était au pouvoir
soit même de son propre passé et aborder
toutes les questions avec sérénité
d'accord ou en quoi un ministre de
l'intérieur ministre et justice un
président de la république aujourd'hui
un premier ministre et moi même serions
nous en fait en train d'applaudir osant
chic chic il faut se faire sortir des
délinquants dangereux ça pas de sens
dire ça n'a pas de sens
nous voulons nous nous protéger nous nos
familles nos enfants nos citoyens tout
le monde n'a pas pu aller beaucoup
attaqué sur ce thème là vous savez le
ministre mais parce que on en fait une
sorte de jeu politique
alors quand on fait un jeu politique il
faut faire attention à quoi on joue
et moi je pense qu'il faut être
solidaire avec les gendarmes et la pile
des policiers qui prennent des risques
inconsidérés un considérable pardonnez
moi pour nous protéger il faut se dire
ensemble et ça aurait pu être la
proposition du député aujourd'hui dire
nous avons voté une loi 2004 apparemment
son application pose problème
renvoyons loin ensemble on est
responsable ensemble d'une société y
compris quand on est dans l'opposition
et attention parce qu'on fait un jeu
dangereux et ce jeu dangereux ne profite
pas une république apaisée il profite à
la république des extrêmes donc
attention responsabilité que l'on prend
allez on l'aurait à sa place chacun à sa
place on va parler des fonctionnaires
maintenant marylise lebranchu
ils sont souvent décriés dénoncé bien et
quand même les hommages il faut le noter
se sont multipliés depuis ce week-end
pour leur engagement dans le déluge
meurtrier dans les alpes-maritimes les
fonctionnaires d'état légal mais
également les fonctionnaires
territoriaux mais beaucoup de questions
se posent quand même après cette
nouvelle catastrophe là bien sûr la
bétonisation des sols le système d'
alerte et puis celle des moyens
également alors est ce que cette
question est légitime écouter le
sénateur écologiste
andré gattolin qui prend l'exemple de
météo france et de la baisse des
dotations déjà le supercalculateur de la
météorologie anglaise et 15 fois
supérieur en puissance à celui dont nous
disposons aujourd'hui en france à météo
france
renouveler tout ça est à chaque fois
qu'ils aient un peu d'argent de réserve
et bien au moment des coupes budgétaires
on va prendre cet argent est jetée là
effectivement il ya un comportement
je n'accuse pas le gouvernement j'accuse
le système budgétaire on est dans une
logique où les nos budgets sont
illisibles ou des coupes sont faites par
des personnes qui n'ont pas conscience
que des enjeux se joue à long terme et
ya un risque alors on en croise on coupe
et on croise les doigts qui se passera
rien alors on a coupé dans ses budgets
et puis on va annoncer mercredi qu'on va
libérer des budgets est ce que c'est
bien raisonnable est ce qu'il y a eu un
coup de rabot budgétaire et raisonnable
dans la prévision des risques
il ya deux choses à dire d'abord le
supercalculateur qui s'installe à
toulouse et que tout le monde peut aller
voir coûte extrêmement cher on n'a
jamais à mon avis en tout cas je
vérifierai parce que je ne connaissais
pas la question je les visite est avec
fierté d'ailleurs parce que les
chercheurs ont vraiment fait un travail
remarquable et en installations et je
pense qu'il est aussi un important en
terme de facultés de calcul que celui de
la grande bretagne qui elles coupent
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup dans la
dépense publique en revanche là où on
pourrait être rejoint vous avez ici ou
sénat des parlementaires dont monsieur
collombat qui ont fait un énorme travail
sur la prévention des risques la
prévention des risques en particulier
des risques d'inondations avec le
problème de l'organisation
l'accélération de la circulation de
l'eau les nécessités des bassins de
lagunage de retenue et accélérée qui
propose qui ont proposé et si au sénat
toujours de confier cette responsabilité
aux intercommunalités
parce qu'elles sont plus fortes que les
communes et puis pour des tas de raisons
les parlementaires tous de façon assez
transpartisane ont reculé la date
d'application
voilà quelque chose qui interroge voyez
même si c'est difficile à mettre en
place
je pense que le rapport de colomb à
celui qui a rédigé le rapport avec lui
et monsieur également mon
excuserons parce qu'il me manque un nom
en tout cas montre bien qu'il ya un vrai
travail et en urgence à faire et ils
l'ont fait avec détrôner les urgences
exil
tout ça à chaque fois on prend un peu de
temps et on me dit ça fait d'énorme
oui il ya des normes mais j'ai toujours
dit et y compris s'il ya des normes qui
protège qui protège les populations mais
qui protège aussi les élus parce que en
terme d'urbanisme
je connais une commune dans laquelle on
a failli faire un parking souterrain
dans une zone inondable
heureusement la norme est arrivé juste à
temps il n'y a pas eu de partis
différents vous protéger les concitoyens
contre leurs élus parfois contre leur
ennemi contre la demande y compris
citoyenne je ne veux pas être manichéen
il n'ya pas les méchants élus qui
seraient prêts à faire construire
n'importe quoi à tout sans rien c'est
arrivé il sont souvent soumis à une
pression leurs citoyens et je pense que
la norme parfois et je l' ai souvent dit
la norme protège les élus et autant
andré vallini sur son travail
enlève les normes pas utile et taille
d'un terrain de basket et j'en passe
autant quand on protège les citoyens il
faut qu on fait quoi on va rester sur la
baisse des dotations avec la colère des
maires qui s'expriment depuis un certain
temps écouter philippe laurent le maire
de sceaux quel secrétaire général de
l'aeem effet qui vous interpelle lahlimi
mission des dotations des transferts
financiers et confirmées à hauteur de
3,7 milliards c'est un montant
extrêmement important nous avons à
plusieurs reprises attiré l'attention du
gouvernement des parlementaires sur les
difficultés que ce nouveau prélèvement
ne montrait pas de d'occasionner à la
fois aux services publics
et puis également aux investissements
publics locaux que ce que nous
constatons c'est une dérive lente mais
néanmoins permanente vers un fléchage de
des fonds vers un fléchage des
subventions etc qui revient sur trente
années de décentralisation et
d'autonomie de gestion des collectivités
locales
ceci nous inquiète alors vous avez déjà
beaucoup répondu au maire qui se révolte
on les a vus descendre dans la rue
l'autre dimanche mais vous êtes là
ministre de la décentralisation et voilà
un élu qui nous dit la baisse des
dotations finalement fait reculer la
décentralisation qui dit vrai fergie la
descente rayé sûr je ne crois pas mais
fait reculer son application jeu j'aime
beaucoup philippe laurent parce que je
signale que dans l'opposition puisqu'il
est dans l'opposition par rapport au
gouvernement actuel il est un des seuls
à défendre du fonctionnaire et à des
fins de service public
donc je fais encore plus attention à ce
que vous retrouvez sur deux
sur ces sujets là le la problématique
était clair on avait 600 milliards de
dette de trop pour baisser la dépense
publique j'entends que 50 milliards sont
pas suffisamment c'est pas suffisant
mais quand on fait 50 milliards ça fait
11 milliards sur les collectivités
locales
le même pourcentage qu'en trois grands
budgets l'état la santé et les
collectivités territoriales
donc tout le monde dit il faut baisser
je ne sais pas baisser l'ensemble de
l'espace public sans les collectivités
après est-ce que c'est difficile
oui c'est difficile je le concède
parfaitement est-ce que c'est réparti
justement sur l'ensemble des
collectivités non non pourquoi
parce que les dotations qu'on appelle la
dotation globale de fonctionnement aussi
à la dotation de base qu'on donne
converse pardonnez-moi donne pas aux
collectivités au bloc communal
eh bien ces dotations sont versées de
façon elle juste parce que c'est un
problème d'histoire pour des tas de
raisons on a autrefois transformer la
taxe professionnelle on a transformé
locales etc
et puis on a gardé d'anciennes dotation
sans son retour les communes indépendant
sur les causes ou le blog non moi je
pense qu'il faut réformer la notation
globale
même si c'est difficile on l'a peut-être
que lorsque certains perdent certains
qui sont plus riches que d'autres
accords il faut qu'on ait le courage
d'aider les communes qui sont en
meilleure souplesse alors là peut-être
vous anticipez sur votre réponse qui va
suivre
vraiment cette fois les départements et
notamment les départements de gauche qui
vous interpelle vous l'avez vu face à la
hausse des dépenses du rsa et elle
explose elle augmente d'année en année
ils ne peuvent plus assumer cette
responsabilité et il demande à l'état de
prendre en charge donc ce coup en forte
hausse et ils ont estimé par exemple
qu'il leur faudrait 4 milliards d'euros
cette année
écouter christian favier quel président
communiste du conseil général du val de
marne et puis gérard larcher le
président du sénat aujourd'hui une
situation ingérable pour les
départements notamment par rapport à la
location du rsa est une allocation qui
progresse chaque année puisqu'il ya pas
pour les dix 10 % de progression d'année
en année pour aujourd'hui le reste à
charge pour le département pour l'objet
du département du val de marne c'est 92
millions d'euros avec lens
le département demandons à ce que l'état
qui est totalement responsable de cette
allocation de solidarité nationale
reprennent en gestion cette allocation
sachant que le département continuera à
agir en matière d'insertion auprès des
allocataires du rsa
on dit que la moitié des départements au
1er janvier 2018 seront en rupture sur
l'ensemble des allocations sociales ne
pourront plus couvrir 12 mois il faut
que le gouvernement réponde à l'occasion
du congrès des départements de france à
trois ce sera la semaine prochaine
j'y serai à cette question comment on
assure salir cette politique sociale
dont on va parler aujourd'hui
héritière des ordonnances de 45
comment ils appliquent aujourd'hui
concrètement avec des départements qui
nourrissent une vingtaine de
dimensionnement en danger en 2016 sur le
rsa il a raison c'est le chiffre et 50%
2018 comment est ce que vous allez faire
pour sauver les 30 départements en
danger cette année c'est la vraie
question
d'abord il faut rappeler faut être juste
on a ajouté un milliard et demi au
département compte tenu du fait et le
reste à charge étaient trop importants
même si on l'a diminué il reste
important on en est tous d'accord et le
premier ministre a organisé un groupe de
travail entre les départements et le
gouvernement pour que l'on soit
extrêmement clair on pose tous les
chiffres en réalité et aux
responsabilités entre le gouvernement et
on verra donc d'ici quelques jours on
prendra acte d'abord des travaux ils
sont tout à fait ils sont pas terminées
on a envoyé quelques on n'est pas tous
d'accord sur les chiffres mais c'est pas
grave le reste à charge moyen des
départements pour le financement de ces
allocations a baissé de près de 20 % en
2014 mais on est encore au dessus 20% de
baisse est pas suffisant pour sortir
tous les départements de la difficulté
je pense qu'il y aura moins en
difficulté mais peu importe peu importe
donc ce groupe de travail va rendre ses
conclusions le premier ministre lui aux
responsabilités dire un comment
effectivement répond à une vraie
question c'est une vraie question
il fallait pas vrai danger on ne fallait
pas passer au rsa au département c'est
une mauvaise idée
on l'avait assez dit à l'époque mais à
l'époque il ne montait pas peut-être
aussi vite qu'ils
la montée après c'est toujours difficile
de transférer l'occasion de solidarité
serait une erreur le rsa était une bonne
idée
le donner 100% au département était
était dangereux maintenant le premier
ministre prendra en responsabilité la
décision qui lui qu'il pense bonne et
juste pour notre paquet d'avants pour
les personnes qui en ont besoin bien sûr
allez on va aborder maintenant la
question des fonctionnaires pour
lesquels alain juppé nicolas sarkozy ou
françois fillon vous l'avez noté ont des
propositions d'étonnantes un peu autant
que c'est d'ailleurs qu emmanuel macron
perrine tarneaud de public sénat va vous
ai interrogé va vous poser cette
question toute simple est ce que toute
réforme est impossible toute réforme de
la fonction publique dans notre pays on
écoute avant cela philippe martinez donc
de la cgt chez qui votre passage en
force sur l'accord sur les rémunérations
et sur les plans de carrière passe mal
il passe même pas du tout je crois qu'il
ya un problème de confiance des
fonctionnaires vis-à-vis de leurs
patrons qui est l'état il ya besoin de
de donner une autre dimension à la cause
la conception de service public il ya
des vrais malaise dans les services
publics dans les hôpitaux par exemple où
il ya beaucoup de mouvements sociaux
bien c'est ça qu'il faut il faut que le
gouvernement dise au lieu de dire j'aime
l'entreprise comme dit valse trop
souvent c'est à dire j'aime les patrons
bien qu'il redonne confiance aux hauts
fonctionnaires et la première chose
c'est d'augmenter le point d'indicé
alors perrine tarneaud nous a rejoint
françois perin vos questions donc
nombreuses avec celle ci que nous posons
sur une couverture mains possibles
concernant la fonction publique
bonsoir madame
je reprends la question de michel est ce
que vraiment toute réforme de la
fonction publique est impossible la
preuve c'est que on a fait un travail
énorme en 18 mois avec l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales j'entends bien
ce que dit martine est sûre on aurait dû
simplement augmenter le poids nalis et
puis il faut quand même rendre hommage
aux fonctionnaires parce qu'il y en a
pas beaucoup qui ont vécu ce qu'ils
viennent de vivre c'est bien un salaire
gelé depuis 2010 il en rend n'oubliez
pas les primes quand même épaté par la
cour des comptes si je peux me permettre
avant ils ont rendu 7 milliards en
termes de dépenses publiques à
l'ensemble donc il faut aussi rendre à
césar ce qui est à césar et ils ont
contribué
ils sont rares pour 7 milliards à la
baisse de la dépense publique donc
syndicats sont quand même divise sur
l'accord alors vous n'êtes pas un jeu je
m'en parlait de l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires je viens aux syndicats on
a fait un travail important pour dire
qu'est ce qu'on fait face cette
situation soit on dit ce que dit
philippe martinez au coude il faut par
exemple on en rit augmenter le point
d'indicé on le reste c'est pas très
important
enfin c'est pas très important on verra
après ou bien on dit ce que nous nous
avons proposé avec autant d'heures de
travail que vous imaginez bien qui est
de dire on réforme les carrières dans la
fonction publique parce que les
carrières s'allonge
on a reculé l'âge de la retraite les
or les fonctionnaires dans les grilles
qui ont 30 ans qui ont 30 ans à 40 ans
42 ans sont arrivés au bout il
n'augmente plus et moi je propose
d'augmenter les salaires
au début de carrière et à la fin de
carrière même si la carrière est plus
longue 40 euros pour une catégorie c 80
euros pour une catégorie b un éducateur
par exemple et met 50 euros pour un
enseignant ou un ingénieur et la moitié
des syndicats vous disent non à ce prêt
doit notamment la cgt et on vient
d'entendre monsieur martinez la moitié
de nos la cgt qui va manifester cette
semaine j'ai tellement pas elle n'est
pas seule de les dépasser à la
manifester parce que vous espérez encore
les convaincre là je rappelle qu'à des
syndicats signataires manifeste aussi
donc il faut bien séparer la
manifestation qui est de dire on a déjà
donné 7 milliards on veut donner moi du
reste mais moi je vous arrange encore
pouvoir les convaincre ou cfi jeu je
pense qu'on n'était pas loin de l'accord
y compris avec la cgt
on n'était pas loin de l'accord
avec fo c'était un peu différent parce
qu'il y avait un problème de gestion sur
les territoires les gestion
interministériel qui ne leur convenait
roma ça n'a pas marché donc on n'était
pas loin et du coup le premier ministre
parce que la situation est inédite c'est
cette espèce de balance à 50 50 prend
ses responsabilités c'est normal ils y
passeront voire 110 les syndicats alors
lancé briques quel état je rappelle à
l'état à l'état c'est le nombre de
fonctionnaires d'état
le résultat est de 59% 7 59% des
organisations syndicales représentant
les employés de l'état ont voté
favorablement
donc le premier ministre dit compte tenu
de cette situation je prends mes
responsabilités et je demande
ils me demandent vous avez des temps des
eaux d'égout démission les corps
constitués le respect du dialogue social
joueurs appellent assez compliqué
faisait quoi bien compliqué d'être dans
un paradoxe
annoncé très compliqué d'être dans un
paradoxe un peu mais ça rejoint même si
c'est toutes proportions gardées
effectivement on a une demande 59% donc
l'état dit oui pourquoi
soyons très clairs il faut rien cacher
aux citoyens qui nous écoutent c'est
l'enseignant qui allait en 2018 être
embauchés au smic
il a quand même bac + 5 qui sera
embauchée au dessous du smic et le
nombre d'enseignants a été intéressée
par le fait que la carrière s'arrange
comme celle des ingénieurs
nous avons besoin des d'enseignants et
d'ingénieurs et puis on n'avait pas
oublié les catégories c c'est un bon
ceux qui font tout le travail y compris
depuis les inondations alors et dont on
dit que leur salaire gelé convient à
tout le monde non pas nous vous nous
l'avez dit donc les fonctionnaires ont
fait un effort de guerre c'est pour
l'ailière d'euros et pourtant les
effectifs maintenant ils repartent à la
hausse
très très simplement ni les efforts
c'est pas fini les efforts nous sommes
dans une situation de guerre contre le
terrorisme les efforts nous avons été
très clairs 60000 postes à l'éducation
nationale on enlève deux cent mille
postes ailleurs c'est énorme et on en
bleu moi faire la même chose avec les
forces de sécurité on en rajoute un
moment le bailleur on enlève 17 millions
devaient enlever
je vous appelle je vous rappelle 17
mille postes à l'armée tout le monde
droite et gauche confondues nous dit
surtout pas là maintenant il faut
réinventer les faux les fonctionnaires
dont là les fonctionnaires parce qu'ils
sont pas des fonctionnaires les
militaires et la police mais cette pause
estivale
j'ai commencé avant les attentats de la
veille 2013 n'ont pas de miettes palu
dernier madame pas les derniers disent
que la décision a été prise plus 8304
nos managers de cette année mais cette
année c'est vrai mais on sait d'où l'on
supprimé entre 14 et 17 mille peuvent
encore issu de la loi de programmation
militaire et que nous venons de changer
notre fusil d'épaulé
sans jeu de mots un délicat donc on a
effectivement la dépasser la feuille de
route du président de la république mais
personne ne nous demande de diminuer au
contraire les effectifs de l'armée et
donc non mais tout le monde est ravi de
la réaction publique dans leur ensemble
mais quand vous voyez ce que rend bercy
est ce que vous êtes capable d'en ici à
public sénat de rendre autant de postes
en proportion que mercy sûrement pas ils
ont ils ont rendu ils sont en ce moment
les mêmes marges je peux vous garantir
c'est toujours un pourcentage en
milliers de postes et c'est très
compliqué et qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
moi je vais partout y compris avec les
maires de notre actuelle opposition sur
le territoire on me dit pourquoi vous
avez fermé tel service public vous
fermez les perceptions vous fermez oui
parce qu'on n'a pas de fonctionnaires
donc il ya des injonctions
contradictoires il faut qu'on discute
d'un équilibre entre ce service public
absents qui crée un sentiment d'abandon
feuille de route du premier ministre
attention aux effectifs sur le
territoire et nos administrations
centrales qui doivent encore rendre des
postes
il faut peut-être mieux organisés
effectivement le tout c'est difficile
mais je pense que les fonctionnaires ont
quand même consenti beaucoup d'efforts
ce qui peut se créer peut-être un
sentiment d'incompréhension c'est quand
on entend le ministre de l'économie
emmanuel macron qui finalement dit un
peu la même chose que nicolas sarkozy le
président des républicains savoir plus
de souplesse dans le statut des
fonctionnaires
quand emmanuel macron disent enfin je
veux pas penser à sa place à il prend
l'exemple de deux cadres supérieurs un
cadre supérieur qui dit stratégiques
économiques chez lui un cadre supérieur
d'une boîte
je rappelle parce que souvent on
rappelle et peut-être pas suffisamment
emmanuel macron je lui dis aussi à lui
que nous avons beaucoup de contractuels
moi même responsable 1
du secrétariat général moderniser son
public j'ai embauché qui des chefs
d'entreprise certes up pour le numérique
que l'open data donc on peut à un moment
donné sur des postes particuliers de
stratégie avoir des contractuels on en a
beaucoup peut-être même que parfois on
en a beaucoup trop
ne confondons pas l'eau la souplesse
dont on a besoin fusion est l'un des
meilleurs macro la fonction publique
la fonction publique c'est elle qui
assure la solidité mais vous ne parlez
pas de l'utah vous ne parlez pas du
temps de travail des fonctionnaires
parce qu'on voit la position des ténors
de la droite qui disent il faut que les
fonctionnaires travaillent ou moins 35
heures ça n'est pas le cas apparemment
de tous il faut s'accorder françois
fillon allait jusqu'à 39 quand la
cantate en payant sa dispense dans
l'andante embauches supplémentaires dont
ils sont en paix un public j'espère
qu'ils font travailler en fonctionnaires
35 heures mais moi j'ai confié une
mission à philippe laurent dont on
parlait tout à l'heure justement pour
qu'on ait un aplat parce que mon jeu
beaucoup sur des clichés un cliché
cliché en cliché privilège dit l'un
moi je veux savoir exactement le temps
de travail des fonctionnaires
et je vous rappelle que quand on parle
de quand on parle de 35 à 39 heures on
paye les quatre heures de plus donc si
ça vaut aussi pour les manuels macron
que j'aille alors quand vous dites
clichés ça vaut aussi pour emmanuel
macron révolutionnaire j'ai beaucoup
discuté depuis avec macro qui a vraiment
tenu à rester dans son dans son
périmètre et moi franchement cette
polémique là elle est derrière quoi on
peut emballer derrière ouais mon bac on
avait ce qu'on dise qu'on dit claude
bartolone le président de l'assemblée
nationale parce que milan gagne
maintenant on écoute l'autre itron et
ont réagi après moi je sais d'où je
viens je sais ce que représente les
services publics pour aider à grandir
des des mômes comme celui que j'étais au
moment où je rentrais de tunisie et je
sais ce que représente le service public
quand vous n'avez rien c'est le
patrimoine de ceux qui n'ont pas de
patrimoine et du coup jeté l'opprobe
comme ça sur une catégorie d'hommes une
femme qui n'est pas simplement une
catégorie des csp
c'est une erreur lorsqu'on est ministre
on dit j'ai une réforme a proposé et on
en discute et c'est normal pour un mini
il l'a fait une erreur ou une faute
politique
c'est c'est une erreur et
politique voilà une erreur il faut
disait claude bartelone c'était dimanche
matin le gouvernement l'a depuis on a
compris vous avez parlé emmanuel macron
il en parlera plus si j'ai bien compris
vous allez faire et encore on a des mois
je pense que tout débat est bon à
prendre ça dépend où on le mène bon en
tout cas vous avez clos le débat avec
emmanuel c'est fini je vois qu on a on a
suffisamment à faire pour éviter les
bruits me béranger son frein il a en
elle ce qui fatigue des citoyens même
alors ce qui fait dire à nicolas sarkozy
maintenant on va écouter nicolas sarkozy
qui dit à maquereau bienvenue qu'il nous
rejoigne finalement il partage un peu
les mêmes idées que nous on écoute le
régime des républicains et pour monsieur
macro que les choses soient claires s'il
partage votre avis qui nous rejoignent
s'il ne partage pas qu'il avoue qu'il a
menti et qu'il prépare son retour dans
le privé la vie politique ne peut pas
continuer comme cela
parce que quand ils mentent tous nous en
prenons sur gérard une part des
conséquences voilà donc nicolas sarkozy
aux journées parlementaires des
républicains la drague moi j'aurais
jamais parlé comme ça j'appartiens pas
ce type de d'hommes ou de femmes
politiques qui passent leur temps
polémique et je crois qu'en désespère
dans citoyens pour rencontrer sans doute
plus encore que nicolas sarkozy il nous
demande de parler des idées des projets
et d'arrêter ce petit jeu infernal quoi
les petits jeux titrage une petite
phrase ayant plus à vous ça vous n'avez
pas le choix vous êtes obligé mais c'est
vrai que les petites phrases ouais mais
l'est elle trouble aussi à gauche les
petites phrases des manuels macron par
exemple un député socialiste laurent
baumel aujourd'hui il dit emmanuel
macron mais qui rejoignent les rangs de
la droite
moi je j'ai fait des réunions compris
vendredi soir avec des socialistes des
militants des sympathisants on dit on
prend acte
effectivement qu'il ya une difficulté
mais on va pas passer notre vie sur une
difficulté
maintenant il ya une difficulté de
langage dont acte c'est terminé
maintenant boss quoi qu'est ce qu'on
veut et hier je faisais une réunion sur
le service public la fonction publique
les carrières j'ai expliqué pourquoi
justement s'était mis dans une situation
inédite est donc difficile et
franchement là ça valait le coup de
discuter le patrimoine de ceux qui n'ont
rien une phrase que mon député
prononce depuis très longtemps je crois
que c'est ça c est ce qu on est capable
aujourd'hui de parler sereinement du
service public et je pense qu'après les
inondations après l'événement de
sécurité après les demandes des cols
après la demande de santé
après les crises d urgence parce que
c'est difficile dans les hôpitaux il
ferait qu'on parle autrement du service
public plutôt qu'en montrant du doigt sa
dépense nous vous dites ras-le-bol quoi
il faut le dire est quelqu'un que vous
connaissez bien j'en doute sans doute
j'ai peur moi de la déstabilisation de
notre société qui n'a pas envie de nous
entendre nous disputer qui a envie de
nous entendre proposé mêmes confronter
nos idées ça c'est intéressant mais je
n'ai jamais nié le maquereau joue un peu
le rôle du poids n'a pas accueilli dans
la famille socialiste manuel valls a
joué par le passé sort je dansais non
mais vous pouvez dire je m'attaque au
totem au tabou sauf que je propose quoi
à dire qu'on ne lui a pas laissé le
temps à la limite c'est c'est quand vous
allez dans un team tant que vous êtes
toujours dans ce type de situation de
dire qu'est ce que je ferais à la place
donc vous dit quelque chose
mais il n'y a pas un vrai débat d'idées
donc moi je pense que cette société elle
a besoin d'apaisement de sérénité
et malheureusement c'est pas ça qu'on
lui apporte tout le temps alors on va
voir si c'est l'objectif d'un texte de
loi que vous défendez aussi actuellement
pour garantir et imposer la neutralité
aux fonctionnaires c'est un texte qui ai
mis un peu de temps à arriver puisque
vous l'aviez promis
et bien après laffaire cahuzac en 2013
pourquoi un tel délit pourquoi parce
qu'il ya eu un encombrement
parlementaire donc ce n'était pas
prioritaire la priorité pour des tas de
raisons a été le texte sur les élus
qu'avait porté d'ailleurs en son temps
alain vidalis en termes de conflits
d'intérêt déclaration de patrimoine pour
les parlementaires les députés etc etc
les sénateurs et tous les grands ce
qu'on appelle les élus des grandes
villes où les grands élus les présidents
d'exécutifs et donc on avait lu un texte
différent pour les fonctionnaires parce
que les fonctionnaires ont en plus à
répondre à une demande de déontologie
doivent être impartiaux et doivent être
loyaux et doivent être digne doivent
être en propre terme probité dignité et
c est justement l'encadrement législatif
n'était pas suffisant n'était pas
suffisant parce qu'on a ajouté la
laïcité d'une main et ça nous paraissait
important dans cette période de
déstabilisation
et puis on a aussi dit
conflit d'intérêts est ce que c'est
possible qu'ils aient des conflits
d'intérêts donc on on parle des conflits
d'intérêts est-ce qu'il faut protéger
les lanceurs dallaire ceux qui dénoncent
éventuellement un conflit d'intérêts
pardon donc on met tout ça dans ce
projet de loi sur comment on renforce la
déontologie on parle clairement des
conflits d'intérêts on parle clairement
des déclarations de patrimoine et des
moyens de répondre à cette situation
parce que nous avons besoin de
transparence
en france comme ailleurs mais justement
vous parlez de conflit d'intérêts et
c'est vrai qu'on a en tête cette
nomination récente du président de la
république à la banque de france
monsieur villeroy de galop il ya eu des
soupçons un petit peu de conflits
d'intérêts et des auditions qui ont été
un petit peu tendue sur cette question à
l'assemblée nationale ici au sénat
françois hollande qui voulait promouvoir
une république exemplaire là est ce
qu'avec toutes ces nominations et pas il
n'a pas brouillé ce message là il a dit
je veux une république exemplaire
donc au lieu de nommer tout seul sans
que personne ne puisse me dire quoi que
ce soit je demande 3 5e des commissions
un dock des assemblées c'est à dire de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
non pas pour toutes les nominations le
rôle dans l'ensemble de nos maisons et
nous en payons assez large et on lui
fait le reproche de copinage mais on
dira beaucoup dans la presse françois
villeroy de galhau doit passer devant la
commission à la fois il ya elle doit
être validée elle sera validée
donc je crois qu'elle n'aille pas
exagérer non plus les shows les règles
des trois cinquièmes c'est quand même
françois hollande
mais michel michel faisait allusion
c'est vrai un certain nombre de
nominations récentes enfin en tout cas
ces derniers mois d'une garde rapprochée
de françois hollande mais aussi de
manuel valls à dents dans la fonction
publique ou à des postes stratégiques
importants ouais un peu une impression
de recasage est ce qu'on peut me montrer
une personne qui n'était pas au niveau
de la nomination dire quelqu'un qui a
fait une grande école de la vie publique
qu'ils passent en cabinet qui est nommé
après c'est normal je vais dire sans
qu'aucun soupçon car proche moi moi j'ai
pas de
deux cas qui me montre qui est un
reproche
voilà c'est c'est malheureusement le lot
des fonctionnaires que de venir
travailler en cabinet est souvent
montrée du doigt quand ils sont renommés
mais est ce que les fonctionnaires
peuvent travailler en cabinet oui est ce
qu'ils peuvent continuer leur carrière
oui parce qu'ils sont loyaux impartiaux
et laïque
une pop dernière que cette dernière
question votre réaction à ce qu'on a
appris cet après midi autour de claude
bartolone qui est visé par une enquête
préliminaire sur un éventuel emploi
fictif au conseil général de la sete van
ly emploi fictif d'un ancien un élu à
moi je vous dis je suis une ancienne
garde des sceaux donc parlons bien
d'anciens élus me suis une ancienne
garde des sceaux n'ont jamais vous ne me
ferez m'exprimer sur une enquête qui
sous je pense qu'on est en stade de
l'enquêté campagne plus jeunes
honnêtement je ne sais pas en ile de
france jamet
je ne me prononce parce que je suis trop
respectueux des institutions feront fut
bien merci perrine on va parler ce jour
des régionales qui s'annoncent donc très
difficile pour le parti socialiste on a
beaucoup dit face à la menace du fn dans
le nord est ce que vous dites donc vas-y
martin je rappelle que martine aubry est
une de vos grandes amies vous le dirai à
déborah clos de la fp alors que donc
martine aubry reste quand même mutation
générale on le voit on l'entend une
cible privilégiée avec ses 35 heures et
quand un calme et à lui lu le dernier
édito du point qui présentait martine
aubry comme écoutez bien la castafiore
du déclin toute la sphère est parti de
ce moment franz olivier giesbert n'a
vraiment pas aimé ça macron comment vous
dire ras-le-bol
la goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le
vase est déclenché l'avalanche de
reproches de l'éditorialiste dans le
point ainsi si le nord paraît
aujourd'hui à la portée de marine le pen
c'est sans doute parce que martine aubry
a fait son lit depuis des années martine
aubry où la statue de commandeur du
socialisme selon franz olivier giesbert
qui parle du totem vermoulu des 35
heures
les mots sont durs et tout y passe
depuis l'accord avec les écolo gauchiste
forgé en 2012 jusqu'à la gestion plan
plan de sa ville et cette phrase qui
fait beaucoup réagir sur les réseaux
sociaux
françois hollande prend garde à sept
tombes reporter et c'est à se demander
parfois si n'est pas plus peur d'elle
que de dèche
alors dites moi vous réagissez à cet
édito très très choquée gérard bon ok je
suis rarement un commentaire j'étais
très choquée on pense qu'on veut c'est
le propre de la presse mais par exemple
sur l'emploi et dit s est absolument pas
occuper des emplois et pas mauvais sur
la culture d'alors l'emploi rien du tout
il faut qu'ils aillent visiter quoi moi
je suis allé visiter
c'est cette grande friche industrielle
réhabiliter et qui accueille les
startups du numérique en a partout les
grands groupes avec ibm et bien d'autres
sont venus s'installer là franchement je
trouve que c'est déplacé de dire des
choses sans aller vérifier alors je
pense que c'était c'est un parti pris
mais c'était très choquant qu'il ait dit
oriali cependant ce qui veut des 35
heures de l'hôpital public même de la
carte de citoyen sociale la capitale
puisqu'elle tout ça pour lui s'est
blessé obsolète mais sur l'emploi tels
que c'est
très sévère gestion de dévorer ses s'est
passé vers je vais vous dire je n'aime
pas ces mots là mais c'est pas la vérité
donc j'utilise pas le mot de sa monnaie
mais c'est pas la vérité et je pense
qu'il faut toujours faire attention
quand on commente quand on écrit à être
attaché à la vérité et à la réalité
sinon on crée un fossé entre nous tous
les politiques les médias les citoyens
qui ne croient plus en rien alors
l'autre question la grande question con
ce progrès bord assure martine aubry
qu'est ce que vous lui demandez à
martine aubry d'aller comme candidate
dans la région mena non je suis jamais
demandé d'ailleurs martine aubry est la
première et on en a assez féliciter ou à
ces critiques et avoir défendu le non
cumul des grands exécutif
elle l'a fait en tout le temps où elle
était première secrétaire elle a
présenté sa à un congrès elle a été non
seulement applaudi mais tout le monde a
voté ça et elle martine aubry qui a
porté ce combat du non cumul et réduire
bon excusez moi là je vous ait dérangé
mais en définitive je ne me l'appliquent
pas en revanche le contexte un petit peu
en revendre dans la vienne il
c'est toujours pareil est-ce qu'on a des
principes
est-ce qu'on a des convictions et est ce
qu'on les applis il ya les dangers au
signal de danger pour nationale et là on
va lui dire c'est un manque de courage
et est-ce qu'à chaque fois on peut dire
mais cette fois-ci excusez moi mais là
il faut que j'y aille ce sera pour la
prochaine fois je pense que le courage
aujourd'hui en nord pas de calais
picardie qui est une région qui a été
réécrit des réécrite avec cette
difficulté qu'au nom c'est le courage
c'est d'aller faire campagne et moi j'ai
vu martine aubry faire campagne marie
pier import bien dossier tillon qu'on
dit pierre de saintignon
c'est un de ceux qui a porté avec
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprises la
création d'emplois le développement
économique est quelqu'un qui en plus a
beaucoup travaillé et ça c'était très
intéressant mais il fait pas le poids
médiatique en tout les continuations
en plus sans le lien entre l'entreprise
et des jeunes
est-ce qu'il faut des têtes d'affiché
parce que ce sont des têtes d'affiché ou
est-ce qu'il faut des gens qui savent
faire qui savent où ils vont qui savent
pourquoi ils vivent et peut-être qu'à
force de dire mon me le disait pareil
dans la ville de mauléon n'y a que toi
qui peux être mère non c'est pas vrai ce
n'est pas vrai il faut arrêter de penser
que parce que quelqu'un ait connu de
prendre tous les postes n'ont en
revanche pour faire campagne martine
aubry fait campagne et je pense que
panne quand elle dit j'en ai ras-le-bol
des phrases d' emmanuel macron quand
elle sent y compris chez ses propres
fonctionnaires vous faisait la mairie
c'est à de la ghréline haute et urbaines
comme moi quand je rencontrais les
syndicats que même si la phrase elle
n'était pas alors n'aurait pas dû la
détacher de son contexte bon il ya eu
tout un jeu derrière qui a été fait sans
aucun doute quand on sent des gens qui
se sentent eux-mêmes
déstabilisé par la phrase dans leurs
fonctions dans les gens dont on a besoin
de tous les jours par les dix pompiers
tout à l'heure de ceux qui nettoient de
ceux qui assurent la sécurité de ceux
qui font marcher les écoles maternelles
et j'en passe dans les communes il faut
aussi dire un moment donné oui il faut
faire attention soyons tous attentifs à
nos paroles parce que nos fonctionnaires
comme tous les citoyens comme les
journalistes ont besoin de
reconnaissance on reste sur les
régionales la gauche largement la place
de posture dans un certain nombre de
régions on prône l'union de la gauche
jean christophe cambadélis un maine un
référendum sur la table vous pensez que
c'est une bonne initiative
on se pose à payer 1 contre référendum
qui vient d'arriver
c'est en temps de ça voilà qui la
propose non pas une question sur l'union
mais sur une vraie politique de gauche
voilà qu'est ce que je crois honnêtement
et j'en veux dire en sincérité
la situation est difficile elle est
difficile parfois on a l'impression
qu'elle nous échappe un peu et que le
front national fait ses choux gras
d'ailleurs je vous rappelle que le front
national est le premier à dire haut et
fort il faut augmenter le point d'indicé
fonctionnaires font augmenter le nombre
de fonctionnaires et il faut les
défendre contre je vous rappelle ça
quand on est dans cette situation la
ligne l'union au premier tour peut
empêcher le pire chacun doit réagir en
termes de responsabilité aux
responsabilités là où il est mais
j'entends aussi d'autres qui disent je
crois que j'aurais plus de voix si je me
présente au premier tour j'aurais
préféré lyon je préfère l'union je
préférerai toujours l'union parce que je
ne crois pas qu'ils aient pas apte à
gérer comme le parti socialiste je ne
crois pas que ce sera facile de passer
des accords entre deux tours c'est
déstabilisant on est parfois amené à se
critiquer un peu fort et que quand même
quand on regarde nos régions quand on
regarde le bilan des régions
quand on regarde qui était dans les
exécutifs c'est beaucoup une gauche unie
qui présentait un bilan compris là où
j'habite ambre en bretagne quand après
on dit ben voilà on va pas on a le même
bilan ou presque mais on va pas se
priver
quelle va être la stratégie justement on
indiqué de mêmes quand même cet appel
est ce qui va être entendue est ce qu'on
va voir plus d'union quand on a
aujourd'hui
personnellement je n'ai indique si non
recevoir eh bien les us avaient fait non
il faut toujours espérer avec des choses
s'arrangent bon si elle ne s'arrange pas
on fera avec
dire qu'on n'ira en campagne avec une
difficulté bon l'assumera me vois aussi
qu'il ya des dissensions des petites
musiques un peu différente sur ce qu'il
faut faire sur le front républicain
est-ce qu'il faut tout faire départ
annoncé la nouvelle sur le front et
réplique à cette autre chose la droite a
d'ores et déjà dit que ça n'existerait
pas la montre est malheureusement
quant à lui vise aussi à gauche et je
vous propose des bouquets ont donc c'est
un autre sujet deux versions
enfin deux approches différentes du
front républicain en cas de menace du
front national en décembre prochain dans
plusieurs régions on pense bien sûr au
nord pas de calais picardie et pire les
régions paca et bien ce sont les propos
de manuel valls et de votre collègue
jean marie le guen que l'on écoute sur
cette question ils ne disent pas la même
chose
il n'y a pas de nimy de peut-être que
oui peut-être que non il y à un refus
direct franc unanime des extrêmes si on
ne fait pas cela on commet une faute
mais dans un certain nombre de campagnes
je pense notamment avec ce qui se passe
avec monsieur estrosi
dans la région paca il n'y a pas de
différence entre la candidate du front
national et monsieur estrosi chacun
faisant la course à l'échalote et il est
absolument impensable d'imaginer
d'appeler des électeurs de gauche à se
rassembler ou à voter pour un candidat
qui défend ce type d'opinion alors vous
êtes plutôt ovale
il ya deux choses d'abord il ya le fait
quand on ne s'alliera jamais obtient ça
c'est important de le rappeler parce
qu'on entend tout et son contraire sur
les territoires attention on l'entend
pas
encore entendu un politique est
dangereuse a évoqué une entente avec les
républicains jean marc denjean minérale
et d'une entente
oui estrosi c'est compliqué moi
j'entends ce qu'il dit bon je reste
persuadé qu'en même qu'aujourd'hui
devant le drame le drame j'ai pas
d'autre mot que serait une arrivée au
pouvoir du front national et on
n'imagine pas les conséquences sont les
mesures pas ce qu'est la politique
fiction n'existe pas effectivement le
front républicain reste une réponse moi
ce qui me déstabilise profondément
aujourd'hui ce que je n'entends pas la
même chose chez les républicains qui ont
pris le mot en plus je pense que prenons
ce mot là il aurait dû être très clair
aussi et ne l'ont pas été au moment des
partenaires encore complètement et moi
je suis très inquiète
on n'est pas on n'est pas au clair
pourquoi parce que l'on joue un premier
tour mais on va pas déjà annoncé à tout
le monde qu'on a perdu quand non mais
vous soyez prêt par exemple un voyage
socialiste renoncer à tout élu par
exemple à toute présence dans les
exécutifs régionaux pourront faire
valoir leur égard vous avez dit oui oui
pour le front national oui je pense en
revanche qu'il faut bien regarder et
c'est ce que j'avais dit je le dis
publiquement lorsque j'étais à une
réunion à marseille
si on a une triangulaire et si la main
nombre d'élus des deux compte tenu de la
prime et c'est n'était pas un danger il
faut regarder ça de près c'est pas si
simple
et je pense d'ailleurs qu'ils compris
nos électeurs ne savent pas la prime à
la liste car il en retard en tête par
dents et ne joue pas tout ça on a
énormément de travail pédagogique à
faire avant parce qu'aujourd'hui nos
citoyens pensent que si à trois listes
peu importe celui qui est devant les
deux républicains entre guillemets
républicain et listes de gauche feront
plus l'élu que le front national
ils oublient la prime majoritaire donc
on a beaucoup de choses à écrire et moi
je pense que dire aujourd'hui alors
qu'on était temps entreront campagne que
les listes ne sont pas déposés que les
programmes ne sont pas tous écrit déjà
non faut arrêtez moi je suis militante
avant des nominés
ce serait la militante que je suis moi
elle se bat pour que l'on puisse parler
politique jusqu'en décembre suffisamment
clairement pour éviter on a quand même
fondamentalement vous êtes d'accord pour
un front républicain retour je laisse ou
sociales et même si elle avait dit même
si je l' ai toujours dit en 2002 j'ai
regretté que la présidence chirac ne
tiennent pas compte
j'étais passée a comme toujours donc la
militante que vous êtes comment elle
voit la carte de france pour le parti
socialiste qu'elle fait la politique
fiction nancy ont gagné toutes les
régions confortablement je serai la
première étonnée je vous suivez lucide
je suis réaliste
on est en difficulté mais on est très en
difficulté début octobre
au delà du magnolia seul mail d'octobre
on va gagner la bretagne
ils sont friands c'est à y aller à la
première banderille en attendant j jean
yves le drian est demandé c'est clair
c'est une chance formidable si la file à
une grande densité and qu'il est aimé et
que les gens l'identifient à la bretagne
s'il ne s'il était empêché on se
poserait la question mais pour l'instant
il n'a pas donné de réponse définitive
il est demandé donc moi j'ai toujours
dit du toujours si effectivement en
10ème agent il faut pas y aller est ce
que tu peux gagner s'il faut que j'y
aille j'irai alors c'est pas mais j'ai
toujours dit ça donne et je la mets
d'apparat me n'ai jamais changé d'avis
je pense aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas le
scénario je pense aujourd'hui que le
scénario c'est jean yves le drian
candidats je pense que c'est le meilleur
des scénarios
il ya aussi d'autres candidats possibles
j'ai même cité jean jacques urvoas et
aiguilles heneghan puis récemment je
pense que il ya une telle demande que je
ne vois pas comment jean yves le drian
ne peut pas y aller man quitte à
réfléchir à comment on gère la situation
moi vous savez rien ne m'effraie et les
citoyens non plus je me souviens toutes
proportions gardées bien évidemment
avoir été garde des sceaux est candidate
en disant je suis candidat qui donnerait
à m
mais je ne serai pas mère et la fin de
mon mandat les citoyens ont quand même
voté pour moi jean yves le drian peut
rester muet
est possible je pense que tout est
possible
à une condition à une condition claire
c'est qu'on dit la vérité aux citoyens
donc on peut dire monsieur le drian on
reste à la défense et pierrick massiot
qui est président et un cadre régional
alors là c'est moi qui serai assez en
tout cas abidal mais notre idée est
strictement personnelle n'a été discutée
nulle part et j'en ai rien à leur
reprocher mais je parle d'expérience
quand on éteint dans un gouvernement on
peut dire aux citoyens je me présente
parce que lorsque je sors du
gouvernement je reviens vers vous en
attendant que je revienne vers vous il y
aura un numéro 2 pourquoi on verra si
free a condamné ce soit clair et on
verra si ce schéma est retenue on va
dire un mot pour conclure d'avoir des
réformes constitutionnelles
puisqu'il ya récemment les conclusions
de la commission qui a été mise en place
par claude bartolone donc chargé de
faire des propositions 17 au total
le retour au sceptre septennat non
renouvelables les législatives avant la
présidentielle
quoi qu'il en soit et petit moine
parlementaire vous allez répondre mais
écoutez d'abord ce qu'en dit et gérard
larcher
même constat divorce entre politiques et
citoyens nous avons le même constat lui
pense que la solution c'est la réforme
institutionnelle
moi je dis non ce constat si quoi c'est
le résultat de la crise économique et
social ces le résultat aussi de la
parole politique ou y compris on lance
des écrans de fumée pour ne pas traiter
les sujets je pense qu'il faut poser un
certain nombre de questions qui n'est
pas illégitime de faire mieux
fonctionner le parlement
c'est ce que le sénat a conduit
diminution pourquoi pas du nombre de
parlementaires
je rappelle que c'est françois
mitterrand qui les a augmentées tous
ceux ci sont des questions légitimes
elle ne signifie pas de boules vers
l'accession alors il a raison a raison
c'est pas une demande quand on est sur
les marchés dans les réunions à la
demande
régnante des citoyens sauf que les
citoyennes nous disent globalement
essayer de faire mieux essayer de faire
mieux sur les collectivités locales
c'est pour ça que je porte cette réforme
avec beaucoup d enthousiasme essayer de
faire mieux d'avoir moins de strates
mois ferme et par le face au chômage et
une demande des résultats d'abord
d'abord ils essaient et non pas des
questions vous avez raison ils n'ont pas
des questions spécifiques sur la réforme
institutionnelle même si dit je vous le
rappelle aussi à chaque fois essayer de
faire mieux
non ils ne sont pas tout à fait à l'aise
dans le système
en revanche je pense que la crise
majeure est une crise économique et
sociale elle a commencé en 2008 elle est
ancienne elle est difficile et je pense
qu'il faut effectivement qu'on a des
résultats en termes économiques et
générales m dit ça va alimenter le débat
présidentiel pour vous c'est pas une
priorité alors sur l'indépendance de la
magistrature peut-être sans doute
n'aurait les dissidents qui n'arrivait
doivent avoir
et puis je ne sais pas d'autres sujets
comme le vote des étrangers aux
élections locales quand on vend depuis
trop longtemps qu'ils atteindront
crevettes qui seront dans le débat
présidentiel mais il ya quand même une
urgence qui est le développement
économique de ce pays
est ce que vous êtes et ce que vous êtes
sûr que françois hollande pourra se
représenter en 2017 oui moi je veux
qu'il se représente
vous le voulez ils le pouvoir j'ai
toujours la fiction bien sûr qu'il le
pourra et de poids en tout état de cause
il le poids parce que lorsque je me bats
on sent le frémissement économique on
sait que les choses vont s'arranger il
faut tenir il faut tenir
merci merci beaucoup madame à miss merci
deborah merci à tous bon soir et a très
vite la semaine prochaine